le parti socialiste on évoque s'effondre
c'est aussi parce que la france
insoumise réalise de très bons scores
dans les yvelines
jean luc mélenchon totalise 36,36 pour
36 6% mureaux il attend vous allez voir
les 22,20 % à plaisir les 34% à la
verrière ou encore les 32 on l'évoquait
tout à l'heure 32 6% à trappes écouter
luc miserait il est élu d'opposition à
trappes justement candidat pour le pcf
aux législatives sur la 11e
circonscription
c'est le fruit d'une très belle campagne
il aurait fallu qu'on rassemble encore
plus bien on
on a quand même l'espoir que derrière
bien sûr il ya le deuxième tour mais il
ya aussi les élections législatives et
là on a besoin de deux députés qui met
en place une politique vraiment orienté
vers la population et non pas vers les
financiers ce qui est le cas aussi bien
de mâcon que de marine le pen donc
marine le pen y bien sûr pour nous c'est
inacceptable
donc on aura le réflexe républicain
en tout cas moi je l'aurais après chacun
fera ce qu'il voudra édition spéciale
sûreté des téléfilms nous revenons sur
cette élection présidentielle on évoque
aussi les élections législatives parce
qu'il ya tout de même une question est
ce que la france 1 sont mises
aujourd'hui peut espérer obtenir le même
résultat que jean luc mélenchon avec ses
différents candidats
probablement pas parce que je viens ici
pour la france insoumise un effet très
personnelles via la figure de mélenchon
qui pendant cette campagne
en effet est excellent enfin c'est
facile à dire après mais on l'a dit
pendant aussi 577 candidats autres que
mélenchon même qui se réclament de lui
ça peut-être pas la même efficacité
vraiment porter mais il ya peut-être
pour la france insoumise une carte
importante et intéressante à jouer
explique aussi peut-être que jean luc
mélenchon pour l'instant préfère garder
le silence depuis depuis hier soir
avant de parler des plus petites
formations de leurs résultats dans le
département écouter thibault marshall
c'est l'un des membres des insoumis sur
50 en libye jean luc mélenchon n'a pas
donné de consigne parce que ça ne
devrait pas être une surprise ça devrait
pas être anormal que l'on demandé aux
militants de se prononcer avant de
prendre une décision
autre chose on voit que ceux qui se
félicitent de cette élection eh bien
c'est madame merkel et les marchés
financiers évidemment ceux qui habitent
à proximité d'une dune qui avance ou de
la montée des eaux à cause du
dérèglement climatique
eux sont bien plus endettés par cette
situation
ainsi que tous les précaires évidemment
ceux qui vendent leur force de travail
et qui vont connaître des lois elle
comme riz plus plus avec ce qui va nous
arriver par la suite